c'est un secteur frappé par
l'augmentation des prix du carburant le
transport routier c'est le cas du groupe
legendre située à trappes les camions de
cette société assure une cinquantaine de
tourner par jour en ile de france et
depuis début 2000 21 le constat est
clair le prix du carburant a augmenté de
24 centimes en moyenne nous cinquante
tournées ont fait à peu près 14 mille
kilomètres pas un jour ce qui fait
environ 4000 litres de gasoil consommé
chaque jour
si on multiplie ses 4000 litres par les
24 centimes grosso modo on arrive à peu
près à une augmentation de nos coûts et
je lui bien de nos coûts qui est de
l'ordre de 1000 euros par jour au total
à la fin de l'année la hausse des coûts
engendrés par le carburant devrait
atteindre les 250 mille euros pour
limiter l'impact le groupe legendre a
augmenté ses prix d'autres solutions
sont déjà en place pour diminuer la
consommation en carburant nous avons des
formations continues à la conduite
économique de la part de nos conducteurs
les matériels évoluent les moteurs
évolue le ce qui permet encore de
baisser la consommation le troisième
moyen c'est l'optimisation c'est des
meilleurs taux de chargement donc c'est
l'utilisation à et l'amélioration de
l'utilisation de la planification des
tournées de nos véhicules autre
phénomène la pénurie des composants
électroniques spécialisé dans la
distribution de ses produits la pme
euros composants située à voisins le
bretonneux avec différentes conséquences
sur l'activité au quotidien c'est des
composants qui coûte plus cher pour
pouvoir
accéder à ces composants dans des délais
qui sont raisonnables
quand on dit raisonnable c'est 30 40
semaines alors qu'il ya deux ans on
était plutôt dans les huit à douze
semaines et sur certains composants on
est au delà de 52 semaines voire 100
semaines 2 de délais de livraison malgré
l'allongement des délais grâce à son
stock recomposant tente de faire face en
attendant le retour à la stabilité sur
le marché des composants électroniques